sorry jellybeans completely in love and  she's getting handed about her  relationship with st. Vincent I'm so  happy it's so sweet Cara and her  musician girlfriends are going strong  she tells the September issue of British  Vogue quotes on completely in love and  before I didn't know what love was real  love now I know the meaning of life is  love  and while the 23 year old is declaring  her love now she wasn't always so into  the label quote as a child I used gay as  a bad word as in that's so gay all my  friends did I'm obviously in love so if  people want to say I'm gay that's great  but we're all liquid we change we grow  and be comfortable with who you are no  matter what that means